hi I'm Nick Gillespie I'm with my
colleague Matt Welch for the co-authors
of the Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America we're doing ask a
libertarian today where we're taking all
kinds of questions from Twitter Facebook
reason.com you name it we're doing our
lightning round number two from the
letters Jesse Walker is the managing
editor of Reason magazine asks in the
opening bath of faces by which he means
the little thing that begins each one of
these videos were you see all the old
dudes who's the fellow next to me zhis
with a prominent chin I'd be Joseph
Schumpeter Sean Peter however you want
to call it he coined the term creative
destruction and his great classic
capitalism socialism and democracy is
well worth reading he also is a plays a
prominent role probably the most
prominent role of any economist in our
yeah i would say sonic is a great book
Matt Jonathan campton from letters assts
Anarchy or minarik a I think the obvious
answer that is anarchy in the UK and so
on
uh Jonathan and Canton also asks Nick
Austrian school or Chicago see I was
going to say school of hard knocks but
if it came down to making a choice I'd
give it the Austrian school just because
I liked their emphasis on the limits of
knowledge rather than certitude i'm
partial to old school myself I so next
question you asked that too in all
seriousness says sudden from the
comments of reason.com in all
seriousness what ought to be the first
concrete policy priority of the
libertarian-leaning administration were
that even possible given the present
political circumstances and considerable
restraints obviously the presidents in
our debased current system of executive
power gone mad has the most control over
foreign policy compared to other domains
in life and also law enforcement so I
would answer a two-headed way basically
start getting some of the bases closed
overseas some of the troops back home
that were no longer defending north to
south korea from north korea and also
stop prosecuting the drug war there's a
lot of discretionary ability for a
president to no longer order of the
arrests willy-nilly of americans it
would also be great to have a president
who actually insisted on passing a
budget Wally's president rather than a
stimulus program oh that's just crazy
libertarian topi and talk it certainly
is Troy Coombs from face via Facebook
ass is an act of eminent domain ever
justified by a government at any level
yeah sure it's in the Constitution as
long as it's for an actual public use
and the owner is compensated properly
with correct takings estimated the
problem is you know we can talk about
these how can we take libertarianism to
its final aunt degree that's interesting
to talk about and it sketches out your
philosophical constraints but here in
the real world eminent domain is used
constantly in completely frivolous ways
to build a taxpayer-funded stadium in
Washington DC which is not the most
flush of local governments so that they
can know so people who like baseball can
go see a baseball game
it's ridiculous in kilo versus New
London we had people having their houses
eminent domain so that they can have a
new industrial development that is the
typical way that Emmett domain is used
at this point and there are way too many
agencies at the federal local state
level who had eminent domain power and
in ways that are completely
unaccountable all right let's get back
to the let's put the Lightning back in
the lightning round sure is why should
anyone vote you would tell me why should
anyone both you vote yeah I do vote I
vote particularly in local elections I
pay taxes and have a house in oxford
ohio where votes on bond issues can come
down to a couple hundred votes i like to
vote on that I've never voted for a
winning candidate for an office at any
level that's pretty good I think I've
voted for one winning candidate and I'm
not going to mention who it is because
I'm still embarrassed by it but
certainly not the presidential level I
say vote because it makes you feel good
um if that's what you want to do and
don't vote if it that makes you feel
good and if you think you can influence
things and one way together I vote
constantly I think it's fun next
question who of this is via Jeremy sands
on facebook who will assume ron paul's
place in the future well i think ron
paul's position or place will continue
to live on like Spock in the phone or
the third Star Trek movie as long as we
remember him Ron Paul isn't going
anywhere soon he's got a son and he's
got a lot of acolytes he's done more
than any single person I think to create
the next generation in the next three
generations of libertarians to follow up
on that students for liberty which is a
huge grassroots student organization on
campuses are creating a new generation
of people they might not have Ron Paul's
basket of concerns precisely it's a
different generation they are the next
ron paul and and it's one of the more
interesting things to look at in modern
politics that's it for the lightning
round version of ask a libertarian we'll
be right back with more substantive
questions